over watches newest hero anna has seen
her first balance change since her
introduction earlier this month a patch
has been made available on the PC
version of the game that affects Arnaz
primary weapon the biotic rifle its rate
of fire has been increased by twenty
percent and the magazine size has been
increased from eight to ten the
developer has noted these changes for
the world received by tweet character
were made to make Anna feel better to
play by changing her healing and damage
output a bug that saw heroes affected by
an asleep instantly recover when damaged
has been fixed so that recovery time is
now point five seconds John Marston
cosplayer McCree has also seen some
changes among the first characters to be
rebalanced after overwatch is launched
the latest patch sees the damage fall
off range of his primary fire decreased
by 10 meters his ultimate fire fan the
hammer has had its rate of fire
increased by fifteen percent and the
time between throwing a flashbang and
being able to fire again has been
decreased from point 5 to point 35
seconds while the latest change weakens
his long-range damage Blizzard have
noted that his damage is still stronger
than it has been in the recent past as
usual dispatches for PC versions only
and will be rolled into a larger update
for the ps4 and xbox one versions at a
later date the latest patch follows a
major update that introduced owner and
several hero updates including a
seemingly infinite wall ride for lucio
invulnerability for diva from her self
destruct ultimate and above two zenyatta
making the omnicom unk more effective
when going head-to-head against enemies
for a full breakdown of overwatch
changes hero guides and all the breaking
news make sure to rally at gamespot